dans le reste de l'actualité le musée du
compagnonnage de tours a lancé le 3
décembre dernier une campagne de
financement participatif via la
fondation de france
objectif trouver vingt mille euros pour
restaurer 24 conduite fortement dégradée
par le temps il s'agit de dessins
d'aquarelles de peinture du xviiie
siècle qui raconte un moment fort de la
vie des compagnons leur départ pour leur
tour de france reportage signé samuel
colin et clément robert ça c'est l'une
des plus belles que l'on est avec des
bleus magnifiques des peintures comme ça
vous n'en verrez pas tous les jours les
plus anciennes ici date du milieu du
xviiie siècle les conduites raconte le
départ d'un compagnon pour son tour de
france comme ici un certain tourangeau
la sagesse on a eu tout un cortège qui
est passé dans le centre dans le centre
ville de tours peut-être que c'est la
première fois de sa vie d'ailleurs qu'il
quitte la tourelle donc c'est un moment
particulier pour ce personnage pour ce
compagnon chaque conduite respecte les
mêmes codes le cortège mène le jeune
homme à l'orée de la ville décrite en
arrière-plan
l'aquarelle est offerte en souvenir à
celui qui s'en va car ce rite du départ
est un moment important
le début d'une autre vie c'est un moment
particulièrement humain dans l'avis du
compagnon et les shade of que l'on a au
musée certes sont aussi des réalisations
des mains de ses compagnons mais on ne
voit que le président a fini ici on a
l'occasion de voir ce cheminement le
temps la lumière et les conditions de
conservation passé finissent par en
abyme est certaine le papier jauni à
certains endroits même grignoté par les
insectes
et puis il ya les moisissures et les
déchirures un long travail de
restauration est à faire parfois il va y
avoir des mises à plat c'est à dire
qu'on peut avoir des effets des
phénomènes de gondoles mans due à
l'humidité ou à des mauvaises conditions
d'encadrement et donc on remet à plat
les pièces et puis on peut aussi aller
jusqu'à faire des retouches
illusionniste c'est à dire vraiment
travailler la pièce pour la rendre plus
visible faire les retouches de peinture
24 d'entre elles doivent être restaurés
au musée du compagnonnage budget estimé
trente mille euros dont un tiers pris en
charge par la ville
un appel à mécénat est lancée via la
fondation de france
depuis début décembre et on va faire une
grosse campagne de numérisation de ces
pièces de façon à ce qu'elle puisse
ensuite être à nouveau visible du public
certes mais dans des conditions
différentes peut-être sous des formats
numériques peut-être sous des formats de
fac similé les vrais conduite seront
elles exposées au public avant d'être
remises en réserve
sans voir la lumière pendant au moins
trois ans